this is the ramsay show
[Applause]
you can be intentional about your
character you can have money and a
career you are the hero in your story
[Music]
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions broadcasting from the dollar
car rental studio this is the ramsey
show where america hangs out to have a
conversation about your life and your
money
i'm christy wright and joining me today
for fun friday is my best friend
rachel cruz
crazy right i can't believe they let us
do this we this is our job that's what i
want to know someone gave us
the microphones and here we are it
doesn't happen often and i feel like
maybe there's a reason for that but
that's okay because here we are and
we're gonna live it up y'all listen we
are here for you we're answering your
calls
aaa eight two five five two two five you
know the number give us a call we are
answering your calls about money as
always
but we've been on a little bit of kick
lately because of my book on life
balance so if you've got questions about
time management
back to school i have all the questions
being overwhelmed today was colleen's
first day of school and so it's like
you're packing lunches you're getting
through the whole routine maybe some of
you are feeling that you're feeling the
pressure of i've got to get in a new
routine a new rhythm manage my calendar
all the all the school calendars are
coming in all the sports calendars are
coming in all the show up for this
parent and me coffee pta this set the
other if you need help managing your
time
not being overwhelmed rachel and i are
in the thick of it we've got six kids
between us we get it six kids under six
i'll say who had six
you're like wait a minute math math
rachel you're with me
uh we would love to talk to you about
your money about your time management if
you're feeling overwhelmed or maybe you
just need help
making a decision sometimes uh it's good
to have a third party it's good to have
an outside perspective
run your situation past us and then
we'll give you the best advice that we
can triple eight eight two five
five two two five and we're gonna start
with heidi in columbus ohio hi heidi how
are you
oh we lost her oh no that was quick all
right rachel i got a question for you
because here's the thing rach uh dave
and i were on the show this week
and we were talking about something
funny and you and i have not talked
about this so dave and i were talking
about budgeting and the caller was
asking about how do i manage my casual
envelope system like with sometimes i
use my debit card and so on and how do i
play that into the budget so we got to
talking i said dave that's got to be
harder now because for example your food
envelope some food comes out of the
envelope some comes out of your debit
card if you buy groceries on amazon
fresh or so on same with clothes some
clothes i buy with cash some clothes i
buy with you know online
and so we got talking and i said and
then there's just those add to cart days
and he goes what
and i said you know like add to cart and
he goes
like you're shopping and and the website
recommends you might also like i go no
just like sometimes you're just like
feeling like adding to cart i just need
to add and he goes
you should be ashamed of yourself gosh
he did and i said and you could tell he
had no idea what i was talking about so
please for the listener let's talk about
this i was like it started in covet
right like i mean it maybe got worse and
coveted when we're home we're buying
everything online
but there is a real there is a real
effect because sometimes boxes show up
you're like i don't know what i got
oh
it's the worst i mean like in that way
so i have to kind of two add to cart
mentality okay let's have it so one is
just one is just the complete emotional
i just need to buy i'm just bored that's
what i'm stressed it feels good
i haven't bought something in a while i
need to buy something the adrenaline
kind of pumps like the total medicator
right like that is the scientific yeah
you know when you look at purchasing and
what your brain does but how your body
responds all of it like literally is one
of the coping mechanisms sure so sure
now i started an add to cart where i get
all those feelings but i don't quite
press the checkout button you just leave
them in the cart and there is something
about just putting it in the carts
not even buying it
that does something for me i don't know
i don't know and i didn't even and i
don't even buy it but i'm like okay
that's cute that's cute because i kind
of want to go shopping so i'm like i'm
just going to add it it's window
shopping online it is and then
and then i'm you know i can forget about
it of course they send you like eighty
thousand emails so i can't have
something in your cart you love
something sure i'm like i know right i'm
doing this on purpose uh and then i go
back and sometimes i'm like okay there's
one thing in there sure that i that i
may want and i'll get but there's just
something about just
literally adding it to the car on my
phone that that's something i don't know
i probably shouldn't be teaching about
money this should not be my job
this is true let me tell you something i
discovered this week in addition to
teaching dave ramsey about what add to
cart means the the emotional side of it
i go home that night i don't know what
day it was this week and i told matt
about i was like yeah it was so funny
today i was like telling dave on air
about add to cart and he goes yeah he
goes when i go into our amazon account
because we share one right
and goes and i see that card is full
sometimes i just remove from cartoons
it's like that is my saver husband he's
like she doesn't need this she does so
be careful because if you share with
your spouse they may just delete from
you just keep it
yes
okay
okay
yep okay great we're gonna get heidi
back we're gonna get heidi back we lost
her i
i promise i know how to work these
phones guys all right here we go
all right and heidi are you there
hello yes heidi you're with us from
columbus i'm so glad we got you on how
you doing
i'm going thanks and for taking my call
yeah well absolutely we're glad you're
here what what can rachel and i do to
help
so three years ago my sec my second
child was born we have three um five
three and five months old and he has had
chronic medical issues his whole life so
we decided at that time for me to stay
at home and be a stay at home mom but
the problem that we're running into now
i was doing some babysitting on the side
by the side i mean like two to three
days a week
but with his mounting schedule for
therapies and school
we can't keep me doing it and i've also
developed
um severe like ra and having some
anxiety and depression issues as well so
working through those on my own and my
husband feels for the safe safety of our
family and benefit of our family it
would just be better if i stopped
working and just focused on our three
kids and i agree
but we're starting to get a little bit
perplexed when we look at our budget
because we have 11 000 deductible to me
now we had a baby so that covers half of
us like i
my 5500 has been met so anything i need
for the rest of the year is covered but
he has impending achilles tendon surgery
uh probably next month and that's going
to be another 5 500. so we owe
nearly 11 000 from this year on medical
bills and my husband brings home about
60k a year so we're just trying to
figure out
first how to tackle
the medical because it's not going to go
away and then where's that life balance
of you know i spend all time with the
kids and doing therapies and i'm not
going to lie i'm exhausted by the end of
the day you know i'm physically fried
trying to figure out i have a accounting
and business management degree like
could i do something different and i'm
not thinking about it just trying to get
some perspective
yeah so what are the ages of your kids
heidi
um sure my oldest is just from five the
middle one the three-year-old who just
turned through he's the one with a ton
of chronic and then the five-month-old
she's on my lap i'm trying to keep her
quiet oh yeah
well first of all i just want to start
heidi and tell you you're doing a good
job i know it doesn't feel like it
because you feel like the world is on
your shoulders and you
you are doing better than you think now
i want to encourage you with one simple
think thing before we go to break and
that is the whole premise of my book and
my heart behind my book is doing the
right things at the right time
it will not be this hard forever
you are doing the right things at the
right time by taking care of your family
if you want some ideas of how to make
extra money from home i'll send you stay
on the line i'll have kelly send you my
business idea boot camp which is a
course that'll help you come up with
business ideas you could do from home
around your kids schedule but i just
want to encourage you not to put that
pressure on yourself you're dealing with
health issues you're dealing with three
kids under five that is more than a
full-time job and you are doing a great
job there will be a season for you to
earn more money in the future but it
might not be that season right now
this is the ramsay show
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Music]
what makes our show unique is that we
genuinely care about our listeners we're
intentional about choosing the best
advertisers to recommend blinds.com is
no exception they offer high quality
window treatments at unbelievable prices
and they make it simple to shop blinds
shades and interior shutters with easy
online ordering free shipping and a
guaranteed perfect fit go to blinds.com
and take advantage of this week's
special savings
[Music]
i'm christy wright and joining me today
is my very good friend and multiple new
york times bestselling author rachel
cruz and we're taking your calls about
money of course as always we're talking
about time management life balance that
can be hard especially with back to
school like i know so many of you guys
that our parents are experiencing right
now or just the second new year august
is kind of like this for everybody we're
kicking it into gear which is awesome
you've got goals you've got a lot of
good things going on but sometimes even
having too many good things going on can
be overwhelming so give us a call triple
eight eight two five five two two five
and rachel before we went to the break
we were talking to heidi and heidi was a
stay-at-home mom and this is one of the
things that's interesting i've actually
talked to dave about this when we get
these calls about people that are in
baby step number two
and they desire balance and i don't even
know if they know what they mean by that
but they desire some type of balance
but their life is anything but balance
in a season of going all in on paying
off
on their debt and even in heidi's
example not just the debt being a focus
but she's got a ton of medical things
going on she's got things going on with
the kids and and you know anybody can
relate to that if you've had a challenge
with your child that is all-consuming
it's not just consuming from a money
perspective it's consuming from a time
emotional energy the amount of uh your
day that you're spent you spend thought
processing about it yes
it's so draining and so um i love to
help people
kind of take the pressure off of like
hey you don't have to do all these
things you can do one thing of time
what's right in front of you but i'm
curious from your perspective especially
helping so many people get out of debt
you know what you know what i've talked
about this balance but balance looks
different in different seasons so when
you're doing the right things at the
right time you actually feel balanced
even though you're doing all one thing
possibly but what were your thoughts on
heidi's situation because i know we had
to go to break but especially someone
that has so many
things on their shoulders so many i mean
money pressure but also emotional
pressure health pressure all that and
desires to work or do whatever well i
think you always kind of look at the
risk reward in situations right and in
her case
multiple kids again a child that's sick
she's she herself is struggling uh you
hear all of that and i'm like
the risk to the family dynamic and if
what it will do to her if she puts this
pressure on herself is so much greater
right now right than that reward of
getting out of debt four months earlier
right do you know what i'm saying like
you kind of have to look at the whole
picture and yes we are all about gazelle
intensity doing what you can sacrificing
uh but not at the detriment of yourself
right it looks different for different
people and it does that's right right
some people they're able to both go
outside the home work they're out of
debt and crazy amounts of time crazy
amount of debt and you're hearing like
it's amazing you can applaud that for
some people it took two years because of
a decision to say hey for our family
dynamic in this time
this was better utilized for me to be at
home and i think you have to give
yourself permission
to say hey this is what's best for us in
this moment yeah um and kind of get
above above everything else and but it's
tough and i think you know we talk to a
lot of women that
um
are home and they want to go back to
work maybe because they have a passion
or some of them i think maybe feel
guilty for just being at home i've heard
that before and i'm like you know to her
to heidi i just would say as well that
the encouragement of you do so much
when you are home like you are saving on
child care you are saving uh you know
you you are doing a lot of things not
just financially for your household
already
um but for the stability of the home so
that role don't take that lightly is
what i would you know encourage her to
do as well and anyone listening because
but it's tricky it's hard and i i mean
you and i we know this but i'm like
i think men and women have
different maybe same type of struggles
in different ways different struggles
different times i mean all of it right
but as a mom when i hear another mom
yeah like i can go there i know what
that feels like like there's just
something there so
for i think you gave her such freedom
and that and permission which i think a
lot of women need well you you make a
good point with the guilt because i i
definitely see that a lot uh even with
women with business boutique that are
starting businesses because they're
excited to they have those gifts and so
on but there's there's an element of
guilt
for
in particular for stay-at-home moms
because and they say to me their words
not mine i feel like i'm not you know
earning anything and i say to them i go
as radical as this sounds i don't care
if i make people mad i'm like add up
what it would cost to put your children
in child care and pay yourself that
because that's what you're doing you are
saving that equivalent of money in your
in your household and so there's a value
to that even though you may not see it
that's right and so that's a huge piece
of it but you know what else you pointed
out
i think comparison and you talk about
this all the time but comparison plays
into this because someone that is in
let's say that um you know one mom has
heidi's example she's got three kids
under age six one of them has health
things going on she has health things
going on and then she might see another
mom that has teenagers and she doesn't
have the health issues and she's not in
debt and whatever and be like oh i need
to be doing more because she is or we
scroll social media or we see people in
our peer group and our church and our
school and we
hold ourselves to the same standard and
then maybe they are when our situation
is totally different and i just i just
love that reminder um
not only just the not comparing piece of
it but the pressure is off the
pressure's off like like you've got to
do what's right for you and what's right
for you is going to be different than
what's right for someone else yes and um
and so i just love that that permission
because i think a lot of women feel
weighed down by that and they don't need
to well and i had a friend say too she
was like if you're spending too many
plates
you can't keep them all spinning
and no one said it's wrong to set down a
plate
and then maybe pick it up in two years
and spend it again like you know what
i'm saying like you get to create a life
that you love you get to make these
decisions and so there's a level of
control we have to put back in but when
we're like you said when we're focusing
on what everyone else is doing and what
you think quote-unquote i should be
doing right then it screws with
everything well and sometimes it can
start as a simple idea in your head my
um best friend jenny sent me a message
uh this morning we were just playing
catch up because she lives a little
further away and she said i said you
know give me an update on your life and
she said well you know the kids started
back to school this week and she said i
told myself that i would start you know
working part-time when they went back to
school so now i've just got this
pressure i've got to like fill up my
resume i've got to do this and linkedin
and you could hear in her voice she was
getting anxious yeah yeah and she's like
i just i mean i just got to do this and
and i sent her a message back and i was
like you decided that
you can just undecide
you decided
you were gonna go back to work part time
when your kids are in school they've
been in school five minutes you can
decide that you're gonna start doing
that in october that's right or november
like sometimes it comes from an idea
that comes in our head like oh i could
do this and it turns into i should do
this and then i'm a failure when i don't
do this it's like you're the one that
decided that just like you said the
personal responsibility yes like you can
change your mind you can change your
plans you can change your priorities why
do you think that's hard for people i
mean you're kind of in the trenches with
women i feel like a lot in this like
what i wonder what it is what what yeah
is there
a couple things that you can think of
patterns that you see that that cause
that that we put on ourselves well i
think there's an element of a very
practical element of momentum that once
we start thinking something then we
start taking action in that direction
then once we get momentum we don't ever
stop to question it and i've been on
coaching calls with academy members
where they are holding their feet to the
fire putting pressure on themselves to
achieve some goal
and then we identify through my coaching
that that goal doesn't even make sense
anymore they're chasing something that's
not even right for them anymore they
said it two years ago when it's right
it's not right but we never stopped a
question is this still right and it's
interesting you bring this up because
one of the things i talk about
in my new book that i think is that we
don't talk about enough is the concept
of seasons
and we just think oh priorities are a
set it and forget it thing these are my
parties for my whole life or because
something's right right now it's gonna
be right forever
and when you start to look at your
season like heidi is a great example you
we have different seasons depending on
our our family our work our health these
major areas
and depending on the season we're in
that will determine what balance looks
like for us that will determine what our
capacity is yeah that will determine
what we put on our calendar or not but
if we don't consider the season we're in
before we set our calendar in our to-do
list then we're going to pile it on
way more than as realistic or
even desirable for us in that season and
then beat ourselves up when we fall
short but the problem wasn't that you
didn't do enough the problem was that
you never took into consideration your
season when you put all that pressure on
yourself what it is yes
i think there's such a um there's such
an important aspect of considering your
season maybe you're in a season of
getting out of debt and so you are
working two jobs but remember it's a
season that's right when you get out of
debt you're not gonna be working two
three four jobs hopefully you know maybe
you're in a season of newborns and
you're like i don't ever sleep right you
don't but i promise you you will sleep
again when your child is older and so
just understanding how our season
affects us
gives us the strength to get through it
and helps us take the pressure off and
shake the guilt whenever we don't meet
our own expectations of ourselves in
that season yes it's so good and and
again it changes yes it's going to
change seasons change literally yeah
they're nev it's not this um you know
idea fatalistic that forever ever ever
ever ever this way even though it feels
like it sometimes it does it does but
i'm like you can be able to say okay we
can look out here and like we went we
took the girls to florida two months ago
we left charles
with winston's parents it was the first
trip we didn't have high chairs cribs
diapers strollers nothing nothing
and we were like we're here we're
getting there like it's happening so
yeah find the light find the light it's
there yeah it won't last forever
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
does it feel like no matter what you try
or how hard you work you just can't get
ahead with money i know that feeling
it's exhausting
and stressful and sometimes it's
terrifying
but you don't have to live like that if
you're sick and tired of being sick and
tired decide that you're ready to do
something different so you get different
results
it's time to commit to a plan that
actually works
financial peace university is the
step-by-step plan that's helped nearly 6
million people pay off debt and take
control of their money
combine that with the premium version of
the every dollar budgeting tool and you
will make progress right away and it's
only available
with a membership to ramsey plus
decide today to break the cycle of
living paycheck to paycheck this month
only we're taking 30 off the price of a
12-month membership start your free
trial of ramsay plus today by texting
trial to
33789
that's trial two three three
seven eight nine all right we're gonna
go to joseph in springfield missouri hey
joseph how are you
good hey chrissy here rachel how are you
guys great what's going on hey got a
money question all right
um so my wife and i are trying to figure
out what to do now we got we have thirty
thousand dollars in our savings account
okay we have uh 25 000 of student loans
we did buy a house almost a year ago
that needed some um renovation and
remodel so we have about 20 000 i'd say
that until we are kind of done with the
house to where we're you know happy and
comfortable
and we've been on one car for five
months and that time has ended we
definitely need to get a second car so
just kind of want your opinion your
advice on kind of what to tackle first
and then maybe kind of how much in each
category to prioritize yeah absolutely
uh joseph how much do you guys make a
year
um our monthly budgetable income is
about forty five hundred okay
um fifty five to sixties take home yeah
what are these improvements cause
because i understand some improvements
are necessary when you move in a house
if it's like mold or something major but
you said happy and comfortable joseph
tell me about these improvements are
these are these optional joseph be
honest with me
yeah some are needed uh you know
tubs faucets leaking stuff like that
need bathroom remodels some are you know
we'd like to um
updated fixtures in the kitchen and
stuff so we know that sun is absolutely
like yep we need to do it and some is
like
well
if it's instagram worthy you know we'll
get there eventually um but uh yeah like
remodeling the bathrooms fixing leaky
tubs putting on doors and putting new
floors in picking out the moldy carpet
and stuff like that have you all
calculated the amount of things that are
like really necessary like moldy carpet
and then kind of itemize like two
separate lists like things we must do
now to live here and things that would
be nice to do later when we have the
cash
yeah it's about i would say it's about
10
of those 20 that we calculated half of
that is like okay we really need to do
this and then the other half is like
these are some things coming up in the
future that um we want to do and we kind
of like having that security of the
extra you know 10 000 sitting there for
those things gotcha yeah
okay well what and uh i'm sorry i'm
going to ask about the car situation so
you guys have been doing it for five
months how did you do it for five months
and why suddenly is that season over
um well i am an educator so back to
schools around the season
i'm also a a sports official and so i
have to travel for games and stuff um
and so
that since both of those things are
coming back up for the for the fall
semester it's
we can't we can't juggle it with just
one vehicle yep okay
so where you guys are at because of
the house repairs because of the debt
that you guys still have
uh the good thing is you have thirty
thousand dollars in savings so from that
we're going to kind of just split that
we're going to categorize that 30 000
are you ready
yeah i'm ready i would spit i mean
i would spend nothing on a car right now
nothing five grand maybe i mean get a
cheap cheap cheap cheap cheap cheap
cheap old car
uh something that's reliable obviously
we don't want to braking all the time
but i mean like just go like go find an
old honda civic and a cord do just a old
nice car that is reliable okay nothing
big nothing fancy
um you're 10k i'm gonna press you on it
just because i could just hear on your
tone
i'm gonna say do it in 5k okay so that's
10 000 of the 30 that we've already
spent 5k in house stuff of absolutely
needing it and this is pricing out
different options
different vendors don't just take the
one guy that you hear i mean this is
kind of like this is gonna be bare bones
for just this for a little bit
so i would i would find the things you
absolutely have to do and do it as
inexpensively as possible to get it done
so again i'm going to cut your 10 and 5
just for fun
so that's 20 grand left you guys have 25
000 student loans i'd keep a thousand i
throw everything else
at the student loans
um
and then you guys are are close at that
point then
to
getting out of debt i mean you're gonna
be
you're about 6 000 left on those student
loans and i want you guys gazelle
intense at that point i need something
in you joseph
that feels committed okay like i need
you to say i'm done it doesn't feel like
you're super sick and tired of the loans
kind of like they're there i got this
this and this like
if it's gonna if it's gonna leave it's
gotta leave and the sooner you guys
clean this up you get you get rid of it
you get some actual cash as an emergency
fund so when when repairs are needed for
the house that you actually need you
have that cash to pull out and then
from there you can say okay we have our
fully funded emergency fund after you
pay off your debts then we can look to
say okay now do we step up in car now do
we go and look at the house and do the
things that we want to do
more than just the repairs but i mean i
want you guys to go bare bones because
the more you sacrifice your lifestyle
the more
cheap of a car you get the more uh you
price out these home repairs and you do
what's absolutely necessary and the more
money you can throw at the student loan
the faster you guys are going to clean
this up and you're going to be in such a
different position financially if you do
this and you're going to make your money
go so much further if you're if you do
what rachel says like you've got 30 000
you look at that like oh wow that's so
much money which is great that you have
it you guys have done well to save that
up but i want you to make i want you to
pinch every penny out of it and i just
go oh well we can just do 20 000 of home
repairs and then just you know hang out
and let these student loans hang around
if you do what she's saying and you
really put off those home repairs those
light fixtures all the things even the
ugly bathroom you keep that ugly tile in
there you don't have to remodel the
whole bathroom and gut it to fix a leak
that's right just fix the leak and i
know it's tempting to justify in your
mind and go oh but if we're gonna do it
let's do it at the same time i hear you
i hear you i have that voice in my head
too home repair girl but listen you
don't have the money to do that that
would be nice if you had the money to do
that because you have this debt you
actually don't have the money to gut the
bathroom and do all the nice to haves at
the same time so what you're going to do
is you're going to make that money go as
far as as you possibly can like rachel
said and you're only going to do the
home repairs that you must do
from a health
safety
type of standpoint in order to live in
the house even if that bathroom is ugly
that's right just until
you get your student loans and debt paid
off and here's the thing let that ugly
bathroom motivate you you walk in there
you see the lime green tile you're like
this is why we're paying off our student
loans this is why we're doing this
and joseph what's hard what we just
outlined for you
it's again it's easier said than done
because now emotionally you and your
wife both have to say oh no but we moved
into this house knowing we'd have to do
repairs and we were going to do repairs
in x y and z time and we just pushed
your timeline by about eight months
so it's a hard reality pill to swallow
because your expectations are now
changing um but i would rather you guys
be and i have no debts you're not paying
more interest on the student loans all
that like you're out of debt you
actually have cash in the bank so this
home could be a blessing rather than a
curse
and then you wrap back around and say
okay now let's let's fix what we need to
fix and what we want to that and that
and that's that's being an adult right
dave says all the time
adults devise a plan and fall children
do it feels good it feels good to get
the new bathroom yeah it feels good to
do the repairs
on things that are just cosmetic but
hold off and it's what we were just
talking about it's a season it's a
season of sacrifice we're not saying
have an ugly bathroom forever we're not
saying drive a terrible car forever
we're just saying it's a season while
you're going to prioritize this debt
that's dragging you down and stealing
your income
so that once it's gone you can do all
the home repairs you want to that you
save up for in cash you can get a nicer
car that you save up for cash that has
no
payment
dragging behind it and you will
experience that car
that bathroom
whatever completely differently when
there's not all this debt attached to it
and that's what we're trying to help you
do short term it is a sacrifice but it's
a short-term sacrifice for a season
and just know this is our why at the end
of this we're gonna save up and do
awesome home repairs that we're gonna be
really proud of and they're paid for in
cash
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
so
[Music]
i'm christy wright and joining me today
is my very good friend and new york
times bestselling author rachel cruz
we're taking your calls
about life
and money
time management
overwhelm
whatever you want to talk about we are
here for you it is fun friday and we
want to talk give us a call triple eight
eight two five
five two two five and we're gonna go to
sandy in south dakota hey sandy how are
you
good how are you good what's going on
all right so i just finished a residency
um so i start my first real doctor's job
on monday
congratulations awesome thank you thank
you so my salary is going to be
200 000
um and then there's no um bonuses and
all that later um but i am currently in
debt
287 thousand dollars
um
uh the all federal loan set i do have
five thousand dollars in credit card
debt but with no interest um and i plan
on just paying that off like right away
my first paycheck
and
8 000 and savings because i saved up
some books um i think that i saved up to
12 000 total because of my move and the
fact that i have like two months off
between residency
and my next job so now i have like 8 000
left of that
so my question is um
do i stick to the public service loan
forgiveness that i'm currently on
because i'll be at a va hospital
i have 27 out of 120 payments towards it
you know with the possibility of paying
a lot less of my loans if i go through
that route for
um 10 years
so the issue is if i don't stay at a
non-profit hospital at the va i will
lose that
or do i
end up just paying it off in you know
three to five years
aggressively um
that way with 3.5 interest if i
refinance through sofi
yes well
number one congrats dr sandy i'm so
excited for you um
here's
yeah so with these
debt forgiveness programs a lot of them
really cause you to be handcuffed to
something right you're still in debt
you're not in a different way and when
you're not having the freedom to choose
a different spot so if you wanted to
leave the va hospital like you said you
lose it all so what you're doing is
you're kind of giving power
to someone else when it comes to your
money and the debt versus you saying i
can just clean this up and i can clean
it up quick because the great awesome
thing too sandy is 200k you're starting
out which is amazing
so
number one i would not do the debt
forgiveness program i would pay this off
so that you're not attached to something
for 10 years of your life not just the
debt but also the career and where
they're where they're making you work
in that instance and i mean
even with the 5k
and credit card data i love that you
said we're going to pay that off um
you're going to have to have a lot of
discipline sandy because you are about
to make 200 dollars
and there's a thing they always say is
doc itis right you go out and get a nice
car
you're making all this money and you're
done with school you're ready just to
enjoy life well i plan to drive my mazda
3.
yes okay so sandy i mean just looking at
the at the math i'm like you could be
completely out of debt in 18 months if
you lived on like
30 40 000 a year which people do all the
time yeah and you just sacrifice and you
do you live in sioux falls is that where
you are
that's where my new job will be okay
which is amazing too i'm like that from
a from an um
a cost of living standpoint you're not
in manhattan you know you're not in san
francisco like you're in a great place
to literally live on nothing sandy for
for 18 months two years and you can have
almost you have almost three hundred
thousand dollars in student loan debt
gone like i mean
i look at the math when i first and you
heard you say to 200 you know 287
thousand dollars i was like oh no but
then you said i'm going to make 200 i
was like brilliant perfect but you have
to have the discipline sandy but you can
do this you can
absolutely get this debt knocked out and
then the beautiful thing is once that's
done
you have 200 grand that you're going to
make in the next year
that's yours
should i so what i'm afraid of is like
once i refinance and don't have my
government loans anymore i'm scared like
what if i lose my job and then i'm stuck
with the the payments i'm forced to pay
it whereas i just keep the government of
that federal loans and don't refinance
it what's the refinance what's the rate
what would you get different is that 3.5
okay and you would go down to what
no sorry um
so the government is about six percent
and so five days and three points well
honestly sandy the interest isn't even
that big of a deal because it's not
gonna be that long well and there's
there's no sign that you're gonna lose
your job that's a scarcity mindset that
like out of nowhere you're going to lose
your job like we could we consider and
do what-if scenarios all day but you
have absolutely no evidence that you
have any reason to lose your job so
we're just going to go based on what you
know today which is you have a job and
you're making good money
and i wouldn't get all twisted up about
about the interest honestly because
again if we were talking about eight
years of this then yeah that's something
pretty much 18 months or i am yeah
so it's not it's not even going to
really make that huge of a difference
over that short period of time
yeah sandy you can do this it's going to
take the discipline for the season just
like we're talking about but it's going
to be worth it on the other side of this
when you have this incredible income and
you're not having to make those payments
the thing that's interesting though
rachel that i think some people miss and
we talk about this all the time when we
talk about money we're not just talking
about money we're talking about what
money can do for you the options the
power the control the possibilities the
future that you have because when you
have money you get all kinds of options
when you have stuff you don't so the
reason that i love that we want sandy to
get out of debt so quickly with
her taking control of all of it is
because then she has options if you keep
doing this government program you have
no options and you are in debt just in a
different way it's not financial but
you're indebted to them and you're stuck
with them you have no ten years ago yeah
yeah no no options no power no control
and we want you to have all the options
all the power all the control that's why
we teach what we teach so you got this
sandy and you call back when you're
debt-free because i want to hear your
debt free screen
all right we're going to go to trey in
ohio hey trey how are you
i'm good how are you good how can rachel
not help
i was just i'm curious
so i'm 25 years old
right now i'm living on a friend's couch
for 300 a month
i make 45 000 a year
me my girlfriend just broke up i kind of
been thinking
i discussed it with my roommate or
whatever and he told me i could stay for
a year and build my money
the only debt that i have is my vehicle
i did i have five thousand dollars in
the savings i did have upwards of i
think it was nine but i paid the car
down to three thousand dollars and then
i figured i would leave 2500
um in my savings kind of for backup
and then i still have my paychecks
coming in on my checking as well so that
savings you know wouldn't be touched and
i could um give as much money as
possible toward that car payment a month
i was just wondering the best possible
way to save
um with having that 250 a month car
payment
on me making
roughly 2500 a month i was just kind of
trying to develop a plan here
yeah absolutely
um okay so trey you you owe
5000 left on your car right
[Music]
are you on a budget
um
right now i just am i try to do 25 of my
paycheck into my savings each week
that's what i'm trying to do uh
i have a emergency fund account
with like 300 on it um every week 50
dollars goes into that out of my
paycheck
um
and then i have five thousand and saving
okay
okay so trey i
want you to do a very very detailed
budget meaning you're going to list out
everything that you spend money on so
we're going to talk about we're going to
do some giving
possibly some savings we'll talk about
that in a second and then i want you to
list out all of your bills okay
but dollar amounts thanks to each of
those now this is everything from food
from your 300 of rent that you're
staying with your friend
um
to insurance cell phone i don't care
everything that you pay for i want you
to list out
and the goal here is for your income
every month that's coming in
that that 2 500 minus all of those
expenses equals zero so every dollar you
have
is going to a category so here's the
deal you make 45 000 tray i'd leave your
friend's house i'd go rent an apartment
you can have some dignity as a man you
got this
and then you're gonna start paying off
this car because you only got thirty
five thousand dollar or three thirty
five hundred dollars left on the car
payment you got this you got some
savings throw all the savings at the car
leave a thousand dollars though for an
emergency fund go rent an apartment do
that budgets and we're going to sign you
up for ramsay plus so stay on the line
trey and give you a part of our free
subscription of ramsay plus he's good
he's got what he needs it he can do it
he can do it
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
hey it's kelly associate producer and
phone screener for the ramsay show if
you would like to do your debt free
scream live on the show make sure you
visit the ramsay theramsieshow.com and
register we would love for you to come
to nashville and tell dave your story
[Music]
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
you can be intentional about your
character you can have money and a
career you are the hero in your story
[Music]
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions broadcasting from the dollar
car rental studio this is the ramsey
show where america hangs out to have a
conversation about your life and your
money i'm christy wright and joining me
today is my good friend and multiple new
york times best-selling author rachel
cruz we are having a ladies day
laura
i know i know i'm funny about a lady i
know last time we were on together we
just did an hour and i was like it's
like the ladies theme hour she was like
in the break she's like i just don't
like the word ladies i was like
and then on instagram four we were she
was like we're gonna be on
it's gonna be a women's show and i was
like a ladies show and then you did a
poll
and you just said how many people prefer
ladies or women and what's the what's
the percentage christy 74 percent
preferably ladies
i lose ladies listen i wouldn't i was
like yes i don't dislike women i don't
dislike it i just prefer
the
the term female women i think it's
because it feels sorority to me it was
like hey ladies everyone snap our
fingers in circle which i was in
australia so i like sorties too i don't
even know what the problem is
anyways we're here we're here for you no
i don't know how they trust us we're
here we are and it's too late now listen
it's fun friday
we're taking your calls triple a eight
two five five two two five about money
life
business we've got the business boutique
conference coming up this uh october so
if you've got a call about business
marketing sales is your idea good can it
make money is now the time for you i
don't know let's talk about it
rachel is really great at helping you
with your money i'm great at helping you
with your time and let's be honest we
could all use a little more of both so
triple eight eight two five five two two
five give us a call and we are here for
you all right we're gonna go to rhonda
in santa barbara california hey rhonda
how are you
hi i am fantastic and i'm happy to be a
part of women or ladies
thanks rhonda thank god
i love it i love it what's going on
rhonda
well i am calling to
my husband and i have been dieing hard
after attending fpu in 2019
we have paid off our car
we are
1500 away from being out of debt oh my
gosh congratulations exciting
our issue is
while we are perf we have the typical
you know our car has 250 000 miles on it
so my husband only has a two mile drive
to work
but
i am paralyzed i have multiple sclerosis
and i am unable to
get into
um our car
so if if there's ever a situation
i'm
i i can't i go all over our town in my
wheelchair we live right next to the
transit center i use the bus
have no problem with that but we both
feel i'm 53 he's 60 we both feel that
we're at a point where
having an accessible van
is
is really becoming a necessity
and we're just trying to
trying to find the smartest way to go
about
getting that we're not looking at brand
new i mean those vans are 90 to 100
thousand dollars brand new
we know that we can get a van that will
meet all of our needs
um
between 35 and 40 000 dollars the
problem is we only bring in forty eight
thousand dollars a year
i have my disability
and um you know we live on the central
coast of california which is one of the
most expensive places to live
yeah
and
if
we watch you guys all the time and and
i've never
i've never
seen a question like this when it
it really isn't a want it has reached
the point that it's a need
yeah
so i'm curious rhonda and i don't i
don't know i haven't done research on
this but
are there any type of resources
funding anything for transportation for
people with disabilities like this i
mean not to to pay for the whole thing
necessarily but is there any i mean have
you looked into that
i have done all the research and
unfortunately
we fall into the category of working
poor
so we make
just too much to get any
government assistance but we don't make
enough
to
pay for it ourselves
you know our rent is is half of what
he brings in each month
but we've done it we've made it work i
mean
we're we're gonna be out of debt
probably about two months
earlier than what i calculated when
taking fpu yeah and so we've really i
mean we
literally went on the rice and beans
yeah y'all done it rhonda i mean
it's amazing
so it's not a big deal
but it's amazing i mean the work you
guys have done absolutely i want you to
feel
proud of that you're doing what most
people don't do right i mean like you
guys you guys sacrificed and you did it
so
um i i am curious for you with your
story with this when did you get
diagnosed how long have you been
in a wheelchair um
how has life been
yeah i was diagnosed 18 years ago
i actually only
beca
became
wheelchair-bound in
2012
it started 2013 and that was due to
um
a divorce
i was married for 25 years
to
an addict and an alcoholic who
kind of threw me to the side when i got
sick oh wow i'm so sorry and
about i but you know what
i'm going on seven years now of being
married to a man who
who met me
saw me in spite of the wheelchair
and we are like i said we are almost he
has actually paid off debt
that belongs to my ex-husband wow
he
we are a team it's awesome i mean we've
already told our pastor that we want to
lead an fpu class that's amazing um so
rhonda can i say value in it that's like
that's incredible and i'm so thankful so
so thankful um
that your their story of redemption and
your story of some hardships for sure
and you
um are i mean this is this is a hard
situation so what i
i would say you will never call the
ramsay show and we will and we encourage
going into debts okay so like
we can't say just go out and get alone
on the wheelchair or on the i'm sorry
the the van
um that's wheelchair accessible and
taking out all that like we
we we can't do that right so
what i would say up into this point what
you guys have been doing um
what you can do to save and research
what's what is it what is the starting
ban you said 35 000 is there anything
more used maybe there's a family and
they're replacing theirs and you can go
and talk to them and say hey
can we get a better deal on this here's
our situation
and do what you can to
mirror what you've been doing since 2012
for maybe just a little bit longer until
you have that cash saved up to pay for
that van because i know that that will
be a huge
huge gift rhonda and you guys are doing
it i believe that you can do this
because you've gone this far
[Music]
we were drawn to christian healthcare
ministries because we both had young
families and we wanted to have more
children and we had also just started a
real estate company and needed to find
health care coverage that would meet our
needs we were attracted to chm because
of its low monthly costs and the ability
to negotiate medical costs down
established in 1981 and accredited by
the better business bureau chm is here
to meet the needs of your growing family
or small business check us out at
chministries.org backslash budget we
absolutely believe in it
[Music]
i'm christy wright and we are taking
your calls about life money triple eight
eight two five
five two two five taking your calls
about life money
paying off your debt
starting a business managing your time
adjusting to a new season of life
whatever you need we are here
for you
we are gonna go going to go to isabella
in huntington west virginia hey isabella
how are you
good how are you all good what's going
on
so me and my husband i'm 21 and my
husband's 22 and we've been following
dave ramsey for about four years now
we've been married for two years and we
have no debt except for our house we've
been paying for our schooling out of
pocket awesome um but i am planning to
go to med school here in two years and
my husband is currently in his um
bsn for his nursing and we're paying for
that out of pocket and we're planning to
pay for his nurse prac out of pocket but
with paying for his nurse class out of
pocket the same time i'm going to med
school it's um going to be very
difficult for us to financially swing
paying for med school out of pocket but
the good thing is i found a local school
that i can do for about 80 to 90 000
okay in four years which isn't crazy for
med school i feel like that's doable
yeah and we could live on his income
as a nurse prac after i get out of med
school um and i've also been looking
into like loan repayment programs for
like working for a certain
employer for a certain amount of time
afterwards but i didn't know the best
way to kind of go forward with this
because we do believe that this is an
investment and we're trying to do it the
smartest way possible
so i just didn't even know if you all
had any advice on that how much time
does your husband have left with his
schooling
he has um a year left of his bsn and
then about three years with nurse prax
so he'll be um about
he'll be he'll be about halfway done
with his schooling
um by the time i go into med school so
he'll have about two years left so he'll
be done when i'm in med school okay
um
what's
i know the answer but i'm just ask
what's causing you to go right into med
school right now
would you pause for three years uh until
he finishes so you guys can cashflow
this 80 grand
oh the 80 grand over your four years of
med school
yeah so the the kind of rush is i know
this is going to sound really silly but
we were kind of wanting children around
28 years old
and where i would go in about two years
i'd be about 27 when we graduated and we
were just kind of we were wanting to
start a family sooner um and so and get
through it sooner because i really i
kind of just want to i've been doing
school i did my undergrad and paid for
that
and you know the high school like i've
done everything back to back and i i
know i just really want to be out of
school i just want to get it done
i hear that and i and i totally
appreciate that urgency for sure i mean
i and the i think that's yeah
um isabel are you going to want to do
you know kind of what you want to do
after kids are you planning on still
um
i plan on still working and my husband
um i think we i think we both still want
to work um but he is like he loves kids
and so uh i could see him potentially
staying home to be a stay-at-home dad
after i would get settled in and
everything like that but we were wanting
we were planning to probably have kids
during residency
um the reason i basically called in too
is because like not a lot of people my
age are inner predicament and um
everybody that i know that's a doctor
around me took out loans and most of
them are still paying on my friends 20
years later
and we also have a house and so i didn't
know
and we have some equity in that and so i
didn't know if we should
sell that and use that for med school
and try to relocate
when we moved to when i moved to med
school which is about two hours away
and use that to kind of
help pay for relocating or if we should
keep that as a rental property and keep
that income flowing in
there's just a lot of different costs
and i love the options you're giving me
because it's showing me yes you're
willing to do all these options because
there's ways to get med school paid for
i mean there are places like you said to
work to help with that there are
programs to be involved in that help and
we we have doctors dentists we we have
people call in all the time of the show
that's that talk about
how they've how they've been helped
financially to go through it so there
are there are options out there but
but here's the thing isabella is when
you take out debt this is this is one of
the reasons that we harp against it so
much is you add risk to your life
and what i mean by that is
the stories of
people that say well i had good
intentions of
going you know for this med school we're
going to take out some loans
we're going gonna have kids and then in
the process you know maybe
you have a child with special needs and
you're now
wanting to stay home but
but the forcing of paying off the debt
changes your life right i mean we just
i'm just saying you never know you never
know
what life is going to throw at you and
when you don't have payments
it gives you options and freedom and
less risk so my advice to you isabella
would be to do whatever you can even if
that means pausing a year and you going
out and working and making some money
and just banking that money for your
first year's tuition working your way
through school finding creative ways if
you guys do want to sell the house and
use some of the equity to pay off school
and rent an apartment and you're like
you know what we'd rather rent an
apartment for four years cash flow
school and then look at our family and
once we're expecting maybe we can go buy
a house with our emergency fund like you
have options here i just wouldn't settle
for the fact that
debt has to be your only avenue and i
don't think you feel that way because
you're giving me options which i which i
appreciate so i would push into those
isabella and do what you can even though
you want to get through school which i
appreciate
what's going to be the best
so what's going to be the best
use of your money and your time over the
long haul not just the short term yeah
and you are in an awesome position
because you have taken debt off the
table
it has to stay off the table
if debt comes on the table then you're
gonna take it because it's the easier
way of course it's easier to sign your
name but then you're gonna be calling us
back
in three years saying i'm you know
eighty thousand dollars in debt what do
i do just like the call we just had if
someone had 287 thousand dollars in debt
you're in a position right now this
amazing fork in the road where you can
avoid that future and the only
difference is you take debt off the
table and you say either we're going to
sell the house take that equity cash
flow rent cool that's totally fine i
would not uh rent out your house because
i think that you guys have a lot of
irons in the fire with all this school
possibly starting a family you don't
need to be landlords yeah let's not add
complication to your situation let's
keep it simple
and you get the cash whether it's
because you take a job you push it off
whatever that looks like or you sell the
house wherever you get the money from
you're going to pay for in cash you're
taking debt off the table because that's
how
you got in this awesome position you're
in and you're going to work hard to
maintain it but i will tell you it is
way easier
way easier to maintain
this position that you're in than it is
to get back here
out of debt if you make the wrong choice
and you decide to take out loans for
that so whatever you do you're going to
pay for it in cash whatever time frame
even if that pushes back your time frame
a little bit you'll be setting those
future kids up a whole lot better when
you're starting a family debt free
versus starting a family in debt great
question though and i'm excited for you
i'm excited for this new journey all
right let's go to tim in south bend
indiana hey tim how are you
hey pretty good thanks for taking my
call sure what's your question
um i have a small business it's an ice
cream parlor and
um
like everybody else we're so short
staffed yeah
and i was looking for some advice
because i don't understand kids today
and
we normally hire high school or college
kids i was a little bit heavy on high uh
college kids this year
uh well they're all went back to school
now and now i can't even hire anybody
and
the pay scale is pretty
pretty decent um you know
i'm just at a loss and i've never been
through anything like this where i've
had a hard time finding people to work
and
you know uncle joe's money going to
everybody now i don't know if that's
what has to do with anything but uh
i'm at a loss and i was hoping you could
uh put me in the right way yeah well
first of all tim i want you to go ahead
and give yourself a little bit of grace
that you are running a business during a
very difficult time okay so it didn't
just happen in 2020 it's still difficult
everywhere you go people are
understaffed and there's a variety of
reasons that contribute to that but
here's what i want to encourage you i
want you to think of reasons not just
one reason multiple reasons
for people to work for you
that are more than money
what is it is it because you have such
an awesome culture because you have fun
friday where you guys all have a social
after hours because you maybe contribute
to their college in some small way that
just feels like an awesome thank you
create a culture and brainstorm ideas
that are going to draw people to want to
work there at your ice cream parlor
because it's about more than just money
money is not enough to help to keep
people even in a normal work environment
but in this one you got to get creative
think outside the box
and think of something and i hope that
encourages you stay on the line we'll
have kelly send you entre leadership to
give you a boost of motivation as well
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
well no parent ever wants their child to
experience the panic of being unprepared
for an emergency but let's be honest
teaching your teens how to be smart with
money can feel like a big job maybe you
feel ill-equipped because
you haven't always been great with money
here's the deal we have got your back
with our digital self-study courses you
can rest assured that your teen will
know the right way to handle money no
matter what curve balls life may throw
them down the road and the best part is
there's no instructor needed
if your teen has a tablet or computer
they're all set
parents go ahead and text
self study to
33789 to learn more about all of the
different courses we have available for
your middle or high schooler that's self
study all one word to three three seven
eight nine to learn more about our
programs for teens and then they might
just be teaching you something about
money which would be pretty awesome all
right let's go to jessica in washington
dc hey jessica how are you
hi i'm doing well thank you yeah what's
going on
um i just had a quick question about
some parent plus loans we're paying
for my husband's education and
they send his his mom's name
um
and it's about 56 000 it's in his
parents name and
um a really high interest rate like 7.9
percent um we just don't know if we
should make this as part of our baby
step two we've we've paid off our own
personal debt and just bought a house
and a 15-year mortgage like we're really
go cruising through the big steps um but
we just don't know if we should put this
in our name and and uh consider it our
own if we're gonna be paying it
jessica how old are you guys
um i'm 29 and he's 30. okay so is this
loan
recent did he like go back to school or
was this from when he was in college you
know 15 years ago when he was in college
yeah okay
13 he graduated and
what is his parents financial situation
you don't think they're gonna be able to
pay
this loan off or is it is it more of a
is it a financial obligation that you
feel or like an emotional hey this is
basically his loan and we need to we
feel the need to do this emotionally or
is it more financial
i would say both we are in a much better
predicament to pay it and emotionally i
mean
he feels like he owes his mom everything
she was she's an amazing mom so
we just want to do this for them yeah
well you know from a
legal standpoint right it is their loan
um that they signed to pay right it's
that's the parent plus loan formula um
but for you guys i mean i think that
there's a level um
of dignity you're giving yourselves of
saying hey you know what we're adults
and
this loan was for him for his education
and yeah legally she's the one that
can take it and all that right that's
what that's what the deal is
but you guys taking it on um in a way is
very noble it's a way of taking care of
of his mom and like you said she
probably won't be able to pay it off
it's putting her in a situation and if
you guys are able to take it on
um i think that's kind of a beautiful
thing i think that's a that's a gift
to give her and i don't think your your
spirit doesn't sound like you're doing
it out of obligation i think you feel
like you're doing it because this is the
right thing to do would you say
yeah absolutely um so we just don't know
if we should put it in our name or
continue making payments like through
her account
um and if we should add this to our baby
steps to kind of revert back because we
we feel like we're ready to move on to
maybe step four if we just kind of make
monthly payments on this and not make it
part of our debt but it is our debt
essentially
yeah it is i mean it's just semantics
it's just how you're talking about it
because if you're taking emotional
ownership and you're taking actual
financial payment of it then yes it is
whether or not you want to pretend it's
in your debt snowball or not for the the
step backwards that it feels like um did
you already say this jessica maybe i
missed it but what are the expectations
have you all communicated with
the parents about who is paying it who's
responsible for it
yeah i mean it was not um we just kind
of decided to take it on about two years
ago and he was in pain on it for a while
so i think it's pretty expected that
we'll be paying for it it was just
totally but have you all said that have
you have you all had a conversation like
we're going to take this on and we're
going to pay it off
yeah okay great awesome i just think
that's key because sometimes we can have
different expectations like you guys
expected them to take it back or you
expected it to be split or something
like that so just if
if y'all are all on the same page from
an expectation standpoint then yeah i
love that and if you can then do it if
it sounds to me and rachel you chime in
here it sounds to me that what feels
right in your spirit jessica is to pay
it so even if we told you not to pay it
for some reason which we wouldn't your
spirit is what's telling you what you
need to do like it's like that's what
you feel convicted to do which is
awesome so you need to do
what you feel called to do and and i'll
be honest just i don't know
the process of putting the loan in your
name i know you asked that versus
keeping it in hers
i would say
if you guys were able to pay this off
quickly
a part of me would say not to mess with
it it doesn't matter keep it in her name
well it adds to the liability you know
of of her if they don't pay it it is
still in her you know i mean there's
just
i mean if you paid off quickly yeah yeah
but yeah you're right if you pay it off
quickly that's what i'm saying i don't
it doesn't
i don't think it really matters that
much in that way so um but i don't know
the process even to direct you in that
so
i would say continue to pay it off but i
would be gazelle and since i would pause
everything um i know you guys haven't
moved quite onto baby step four i don't
think you said so um yeah i would
continue to pay off this this 56 and you
can keep
keep it where it is
rachel i'm curious because i know you
have talked about this a lot dave has
talked about this a lot but um this is a
great question a great example from
jessica and it sounds like everyone's in
a really healthy place sometimes we get
calls and it's not that and it's why i
paid for my
mom or you know i paid for my sister xyz
and
she didn't pay me back and you know i
thought she was going to and we never
and there's just these weird family
dynamics when someone pays for someone
else's something
and i i love jessica's heart because
it's very much like we want to we don't
have to but we want to and it's coming
out of this like joyful heart and it's a
gift or it's a you know it's a
something that everybody's on the same
page how do you advise people when
they're like should i pay for this thing
for a family member like what's the
what's the kind of like framework you
you walk them through to ask if that's
right for you
well i would say the first
step is to think i'm not getting this
money back this is a gift right right
we're not going to let it down it's not
a debt we're going to loan it out uh i
would say if there's uh a level of
enabling i would push into it um because
what ends up happening is you could end
up harming them more than helping them
that's right exactly um but that's the
people thing when we talk about living
like no one else so later you can live
and give like no one else and you know
we get calls that people have paid off
their parents mortgages right like i
mean these insane gifts that you're able
to do for people when you handle your
own money right i mean and jessica's
that right like they they're on baby
step four now and she's like you know
what we're gonna take on this debt but
technically his mom's paid for right
yeah it took out but we're going to do
that because it was you know my
husband's education i'm like that's a
gift like what it that that is so
um so i would just make sure that the
enabling part is not in there
um
but also i would say from a spiritual
aspect if you feel the holy spirit you
feel like god's telling you to do
something
yeah that's a great that's a great
checklist as well to say all right all
right we're gonna we're gonna engage
this opportunity to do it um
but i think
understanding and the expectation
because like you said we get so many
calls i've even had friends two
different friends that their parents
took out alone for college
they didn't realize it but it was under
their name right
and then they're going to go buy a house
and they pull and they're like you know
and they go and they're like they're
like yeah well you're supposed to pay on
this like i haven't been paying honest i
didn't know it was that you know you
didn't tell me i mean there's just so
much miscommunication that can happen in
families because of just assuming yeah
oh i just assumed you knew right well
how would you assume we never talked
about it so the over communication part
which is why i liked you pressed jessica
on that like that's a key part whenever
you're dealing with money and family
keeping it clean helps with that
communication clear communication to be
unclear is to be unkind yeah you're not
being kind by just dancing around the
edges and making everything sweet go in
there and and lay down exactly what's
going on yeah um because that truth is
going to help kind of slice through
a lot of the hardship that can be caused
by money and family yeah and uh i love
how we quote this all the time but
george bernard shaw said the biggest
problem with communication
is the illusion that it's occurred i
thought you knew you thought i knew but
i said but you meant and i thought and
that's where so much resentment builds
that's where conflict occurs that's
where you miss each other you had an
expectation they had an expectation
there were different expectations and
you never talked about them and so so
much can be resolved so much conflict so
many uh you know resentment that's
building up could be resolved if you
would just communicate if you would just
say what are your expectations here here
are my expectations here let's get on
the same page before we move forward in
anything by the way that's not just a
money principle that's a life principle
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
i'm christy wright and rachel cruz and i
are taking your calls today aaa
825-5225 if you have a question about
money
about paying off your debt about
starting your business about life
we're here we're here for you taking
your calls we're having fun it's friday
we're in a great mood
and we love hanging out with you so
let's go to audrey in joplin missouri
hey audrey how are you
i'm good how are you good what's going
on
yeah so let me give you just a little
bit of purpose so i'm 19 i'm currently
going to college
i'm actually getting paid back to go to
college my scholarships are covering
everything wow you're one of those
audrey i knew those people they go to
the financial aid office and they'd get
a check and i'm like yeah you're the
smart ones that's awesome that's awesome
yeah
so um just last month i pretty much
watched financial peace university um
and my question really is since i i mean
i've never gone into debt um i'm looking
to start that emergency fund and opening
like a roth ira so start on all that
stuff and i just don't i've never done
any of that stuff before so i didn't
know if it's best to do it at just like
my local bank where i have my free
checking account or where's the best
place to go to do those things
well
you're amazing audrey number one i mean
absolutely incredible not many 19 year
olds binge watch financial peace
university
though they should yes i mean you're you
already are going to be in an incredible
um situation so
here's what i would say to you while
those charts that are in financial peace
university you know you see the compound
interest if you start at 19 and you end
at 22 you know you have four million you
know all of this
so that for me is an illustration to
show maybe not literal right now at 19
but to show the power of when you start
early
um how far your money can go so with
that being said
with you being in school even though
you're being paid and you're so smart
i'm sure that
that's still how it's going to be in
four years
the best investment you can make right
now is in you
and so by putting money away right now
that you're not able to get in fact you
have to earn an income to a point to
even open up a roth ira which is an
investment so you'd have to meet with an
investment professional to do that
that money is a way so the best plan and
this is what we encourage always college
students smart college students that are
people like you audrey
is to to start saving and just save save
save save save save save because here's
the deal number one you're going to have
plenty of time to catch up when it comes
to investing in retirement okay time is
on your side you're going to be in an
incredible position to do that
and number two
to be able just to have that cash
because
if something were to happen with
scholarships or education you have that
money there to supplement to continue to
be debt-free while going through school
which is a great investment for you but
also you just have a chunk of money
there at the end of school
and
you know you're being paid to go to
school all of that right so you save
this big emergency found in more cash
you leave at 21 with a pile of cash that
you can use
for not just an emergency fund but
beyond that for a down payment maybe on
a home maybe that's a big chunk that you
ride into a big mutual fund to start out
but having that money liquid meaning you
can get to it quickly with an with a
roth ira you can't get to it quickly it
is stuck in there because if you pull it
out there's penalty so having cash
available at your age is going to be the
smartest move audrey so what i would say
is to go down you can go down to your
local bank you can go online and i would
open up a money market account so this
is a basically a savings account you
can't you can write it usually comes to
the debit card so you can
you can take money out or write a check
out of it usually on average about six
times a month so it's not gonna be your
primary checking but this can be an
account that you just start saving cash
for it's your emergency fund but it
might be even just more stuff so just
having that one account that you are
focused on putting as much money away as
possible
again if you need it for school at some
point you can pull some of that money
out
or the beautiful thing is you graduate
with
maybe ten thousand dollars i don't know
you know and you're like oh okay well
from here we got some options we can do
some stuff because that transition out
of college to the real world can be
expensive so having that money on hands
but again audrey amazing i mean
you're incredible absolutely incredible
the fact that you're even calling the
fact that you watched financial peace
university as a 19 year old and then
called the ramsay show for that kind of
question just shows what a go-getter
you're gonna you're gonna have a lot of
money you're gonna build wealth in your
life you're gonna be just fine what i
what i love about your situation and
like so many college students is because
you have
uh such a great position right now
you're not in debt then you do have
options it's like we've been talking
about all day today money is not just
about money it's about options it's
about you having the option to do what
you want to do whether that is move
across the country or travel or buy a
house or go to grad school or whatever
you don't know what you don't know
audrey like all college students by the
way you don't know what you don't know
you don't know what you're going to want
in two years three years five years but
if you have money then you've got the
options to make any of those things
happen
even if you change your mind or it goes
different than you expect great question
and great job way to go all right let's
talk to andy and boise hey andy how are
you
i'm doing good thanks for taking my call
sure what's going on
so my wife and i are at a bit of a
disagreement that we can't seem to get
past and that is where we should live
just a small thing
we
my job for 17 years we've been married
for 12.
and recently there's been some stuff
that's just kind of gone bad with
relationships for her and she's kind of
saying we just need to move closer to my
family and her family lives two thousand
miles away
so that would mean wow selling our house
finding another house i'd have to find
another job and and it just kind of got
the point where i'm saying i just don't
see that smart and she's saying what's
the smartest thing we can do and i'm
just we're just kind of stuck okay i got
i have so many follow-up questions
number one um do you all have kids
we have four kids and number fives on
the way okay congratulations what are
their ages
uh the oldest is 10 and next one will be
eight the one below that is four about
to turn five and our youngest is one and
a half okay
okay
so as much as you can tell us um that
you're comfortable with what what went
down what went bad with relationships
here
there's just been several relationships
with his friends that they just
basically kind of just
abandoned her
um kind of left her high and dry and
she's she's kind of at the point around
she's just saying i'm tired of reaching
out to people to be friends and then
just kind of just just just believe in
me and then i feel like i have nothing
here she's like you've got your family
here you've got everything here but all
everything that's that's my family that
that i love is you know a whole country
away yeah okay let me let me tell you
what i hear is going on and i'm gonna
show you both sides of it
um
andy one side of it is as a mom and i
can only relate to this from the from
the motherhood perspective but i love
being close to my mom and my dad having
that help having that um support that
that's my people not matt's people my
people my mom's three miles away there's
a very real piece of that as she's
pregnant you've got number five on the
way that i could totally see why she
would be want to be closer to her family
with the fifth baby on the way that in
and of itself to me makes sense okay so
i get that if that was the only reason i
would i would get it i'm not saying you
should do it but i understand the desire
right the piece of it that's a check for
me is i feel like she's running i feel
like she's running from these
relationships that hurt her and if she
was fine before those relationships burn
that bridge
then i don't know why she couldn't be
fine after that she might need some
community she might need new
relationships she might need a different
type of support she definitely does need
things that are hers if it feels like
that all she does is take care of the
kids and you've got this awesome life
with work and golf clubs and all the
friends and interests and she doesn't
have that then
man of course she needs that but the
only place it's possible is not 2000
miles away it's possible there but it's
going to take some effort on her part so
i think that the advice i would give you
and i want rachel to jump in here but
just seeing both sides and hearing both
sides
i think would be really important for
you all to dig into
your her motivation to leave if her
motivation to leave is family and
support with a fifth baby that's a very
different conversation than i had some
friends that hurt my feelings here
because this is a very expensive
decision you're talking about your job
of 17 years selling your house uprooting
your kids out of their schools like that
is a major lifetime there better be an
amazing reason
for y'all to do that to put your whole
family through it and i would just press
into into that conversation and really
in in love andy ask questions like
what's going on why can't we find that
here what's different today than was
different you know six months ago or
before this happened you know let's
really ask lots of open-ended questions
to lead to the conversation to get to
the root of what's going on
so that you can make the decision that's
right for you but i would just say from
my perspective it would need to be
a very good reason
to uproot your whole family take all
that cost rachel you feel like the same
oh absolutely yeah you don't want to
make decisions that are emotional and
out of pain and hurt
we want to make these big life decisions
when we're in a healthy spot and it
doesn't sound like that and for a good
reason she was hurt she's hurt and do
not do it do not make any decision until
you're on the same page okay you will
build resentment if you do keep working
through it till you get on the same page
great call good luck
this is the ramsey show
[Music]
this is james childs producer of the
ramsay show you can listen to all our
shows with the ramsay network app on
your smartphone browse by topic or even
sync clips to your friends
download the ramsay network app in your
favorite app store today
[Music]
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
you can be intentional about your
character you can have money and a
career you are the hero in your story
[Music]
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions broadcasting from the dollar
car rental studio this is the ramsey
show where america hangs out to have a
conversation about your life and your
money i'm christy wright and joining me
today is my good friend rachel cruz and
we are taking your calls about money
life business time management
relationships really anything you want
to talk about we're here for you triple
eight eight two five
five two two five and i want to remind
you guys that my new book take back your
time the guilt-free guide to life
balance
is available for pre-sale and when you
go ahead and get your copy now you get
the e-book free the audiobook free and
you get a ticket to my event
take back your time live on september
6th 16th and here's a fun fact i don't
think i told you guys i mentioned it on
my instagram today but that event
take back your time live is on september
16th which is the week of book lunch and
that is mary grace's birthday how do you
feel about that christy when that
happened were you like
okay this is literally my book it
literally is it's it's it's her second
birthday
i don't know i guess i'll bring her
backstage to see all see all of it
happening but here's the reality is we
are all even if you do
everything right even if you're super
intentional with your time and your
calendar even if
you are doing the right things at the
right time still sometimes those things
are going to collide still sometimes
you're going to have two things that you
love very much happen at the same time
but we will be celebrating little merry
christmas the next weekend and she will
not know that is her birthday she will
not know i will spend the day with her
before i am with you guys here on stage
by the way if you join us here in
nashville
uh for the take back your time live
event you can get your tickets at
ramseysolutions.com but if you come here
then not only is it fun because you're
in person and you get the book free but
we're going to do a book signing and i
don't know maybe you'll meet my
two-year-old daughter on her birthday
there's a group of us here in person so
feel free to go ahead and get your
ticket you can get the book free that
way you can also pre-order your book and
get a ticket however you want to do it
about this because your last book was
was business boutique yep and i'll just
say this when you're in this line of
work being able to do a book it's like i
get to put all of my my heart my passion
all of this into something that's going
to live for a long time so yes books are
always very exciting yes to get a
message out there because it's just in a
totally different obviously way to do it
versus video or podcast or something
well and i've been talking about this
for a decade i know so are you just like
we haven't even as friends i feel like
we have no it happened so fast i know it
didn't happen fast but it feels like it
did yeah where i'm like oh my gosh it's
like already on pre-order and so it's
here how are you feeling um i'm so
excited let me tell you what i love
about it most and you know this because
you've done book launches and pre-sales
and all that kind of stuff i've been
doing tons of interviews so with
podcasts and tv and all that kind of
stuff and aside from the fact that every
interview has been different which i
love we're talking about different
things
what is so fun to help people understand
is this is not a productivity book it's
not even really a time management book
rachel this is about the deeper issues
of why we feel out of balance in the
first place you know earlier when we
were on the show together you know in
the first hour you use the analogy of
spinning plates and i think when it
comes to balance we've got a lot of
feelings around that word we've got a
lot of pressure on ourselves well here's
what i found we don't know what balance
is we just know we don't have it and so
it feels like this shadow that haunts us
all the time yep and we've got all these
analogies from spinning plates to
juggling balls to walking the tightrope
and and we need to know which balls are
plastic and which balls are glass and
which ones you can drop and the truth is
all of that feels really stinking
stressful yeah and i can do all that
and still feel out of balance and so i
started asking a different question what
if balance isn't something you do how
you balance it all perfectly
what if instead it's something that you
feel
what if it's something that you create
in your life where you could be balanced
and still be busy in a busy season where
you could be a balanced person in an out
of balance world where balance looks a
lot more like
peace
confidence in your choices
actually enjoying your life
that
i think is the type of balance we're
really after and that's what i unpack in
this book and so the whole book is based
around my thesis of life balance is not
doing everything for an equal amount of
time like we often put on pressure on
ourselves to do
it's about doing the right things at the
right time and when you do the right
things at the right time you will feel
that sense of balance you've been
looking for and here's the great news
you get to decide what's right for you
yeah you get to decide what's right for
you in any given season so someone that
is building their business and you're
working all the time you're not failing
you're doing what's right for you right
now to get this business on the ground
somewhere working three jobs to get out
of debt you're not failing your family
this is a season where you're doing
what's right right now for the long term
gain someone that's a newborn and that
has i mean someone someone that's a
newborn i'm talking all the newborns out
there everyone so like tell me what a
balance is for a friend
and you're really struggling
i talk too fast i get so excited
if you have a newborn and you get one
shower a week listen that's success for
you right now yes it is
balance for you looks different because
you're not sleeping everyone yeah but it
doesn't mean your whole life is out of
whack because i think what we do rachel
and i think a lot of women struggle with
this
parents are not i think that what
happens is we often do a lot of things
right but then we always focus on the
things we didn't do so right now i'm in
a crazy season with launching the book
i'm on the road i'm traveling i'm
working a lot of hours
so i'm not doing some things i normally
do like work out all the time or see my
friends all the time now i could look at
that and feel like a huge failure like
oh i'm such a bad friend i'm not working
out or my house is not as clean as i
would like or i could say that's not
right right now
so a simple question i love to give
people
and for any of you listening right now
that might be in a season where you're
going i am overwhelmed i just want to
give you a very practical question to
ask yourself it's super tactical that's
going to help you do exactly what i'm
talking about
ask yourself what's right right now
what's right right now and you can look
at that in this season what's right this
season what's the most important this
season you could look at it in a week
hey what's right this week what are my
top priorities this week and you could
look at it in a given day start your day
okay what's right right now what do i
need to focus on today
then when you actually get clarity
around what that is and you spend your
time on it you not only get to enjoy
that that moment while it's happening
and and experience it but you shake the
guilt of all the things you're not doing
because when i step over toys and my
house is a mess i don't beat myself up
as a failure i go that's not right right
now this is not the season for a clean
house christy this is not
the priority right now we've got
priorities and that's not it so um i
just wanna i want it to be a book that
sets people free from the pressure to do
it all yeah and instead say hey you're
doing a great job just simply ask
yourself what's right right now and do
that and when you do that you will shake
the guilt you will create your version
of balance and you'll actually get to
enjoy your life more
well what i love about it is
you to to the point that we all can
you're able to say hey i'm going to take
control over this yeah i'm going to be
intentional right and i'm actually going
to create a life that i want like that
what does this look like right and
and what a beautiful thing just to give
people permission and to be able to walk
them through that so i'm i'm so excited
about it
i think so many people feel like victims
to their schedule yes yeah
like oh well i have to do this so i have
to i'm like
a lot of it you don't yeah some things
you do have to do but a lot of it you
don't
and so it again comes down to personal
responsibility and saying okay i'm gonna
i'm going to make decisions that are
right for me and my family and by the
way your time is not just your time it's
your family's time if you have a family
that's right and so this is a great
jumping off point to have this
conversation with your spouse and say
hey what's right right now for me what's
right right now for you and how do we
come together in our values just like we
teach you guys with your money in your
budget your calendar should reflect the
values of you and your spouse if you're
married or your kids if they're older
that's right everyone gets to speak into
it everyone's values are represented and
then what's really cool is it brings you
together as a team where you're on the
same page and you're creating a life
that everyone wants to be a part of and
you're it's got those shared goals so
good take back your time the guilt-free
guide to life balance is available for
pre-sale at ramseysolutions.com
[Music]
[Music]
stop paying your overpriced wireless
provider and switch to puretalk they use
the same network as the larger providers
for much less for just 30 a month get
unlimited talk text and six gigs of data
with no contract the average family
saves over seventy dollars a month by
switching to pure top just go to
puretalk.com and enter the promo code
ramsey to save 50 off your first month
pure talk simply smarter wireless
[Music]
[Music]
i'm christy wright joining me today is
my good friend rachel cruz and we are
taking your calls about life
and money
and we're going to go to columbus with
hunter hey hunter how are you
good ladies how are you great what's
going on
hey there so i work from home i own and
operate a professional wedding dj
business
but i also work for a software company
and the software company found me
because i used their platform to manage
my business and they were looking for
employees to hire and so they ended up
bringing me on and they pay me through
my business and they keep telling me
they're going to bring me on as a
full-time employee
and i'm wondering whether or not i
should keep waiting for that or just
find another job because i'm still
dealing with you know the business
income tax and then paying my self
payroll and then the payroll tax and
it's just a big headache so i wanted to
see what you girls would recommend
okay uh give me some details about this
position was it in writing and was there
a timeline established when you were
hired at when you would be brought on
full time
um so there was no
writing as to when i would be brought on
full time but it's uh it's a yearly
agreement
okay
and how long have you been doing it
i've been doing it for two years
two years so when you started they said
we're going to bring you on full time
they never said when and you never asked
when
well they they brought me on i'm doing
32 hours a week 30 bucks an hour
six hours a day so
i'm doing just under 4 000 a month
so they they brought me on as quote
unquote part-time but i'm working like
every single day if that makes sense
gotcha so you just i guess i'm confused
on the the question you want to be you
want to not be a contract employee you
want to be full-time on their payroll
correct and i i've told them that and
they keep telling me that they'll bring
me on full time but i'm not seeing any
any like any movement on that if that
means and they never say they never say
win and you never ask when
i did ask gwen and they told me back in
april when we launched our new software
and it's still no movement since
and and have you followed up like hey
guys april happened i have and what do
they say
um the one of our member of leadership
has been desperately uh ill so they've
been telling me that it's because of
that but i i don't think it is because
it's been a recurring thing
okay
well
let me ask you this how bad do you want
it
like
do you want this position with this
company enough to stick around and try
to work it out with them or is it like
you're not you don't really care and you
kind of are good to have a reason to go
find something different
well i i love the atmosphere i love the
ability to work from home uh and you
know i love it uh it's just i would like
to be able to take some of that uh
that tax worriness off of off of myself
just by being a w-2 employee yeah well
for sure
um
you know i hate to oversimplify this but
i think that you know we were talking
earlier about communication i think this
is going to require you being super
persistent in communicating with them
and following up and you can be really
direct hunter and you can be really kind
and it would look something like this to
whoever your leader is say hey i love
working for this company in fact i love
it so much i've turned on other work in
order to be able to do this
but i'm taking xyz tax burden
and that just doesn't make sense
financially for me because i could go
work a full-time job somewhere else that
doesn't have that tax burden so if i'm
gonna be able to stay with you guys i'm
gonna need to come on full-time like we
talked about two years ago like you guys
promised through april
and if we can't have a hard deadline
that that's going to happen by i'm
probably going to need to look for
something else
and it's very kind and what's what's so
important about this hunter is you're
putting it back on them
you're not the one that made this
promise they're the one that made the
promise and taking into consideration
health or leadership change or anything
you could absolutely do that and be kind
and you have been because by the way
april was a long time ago it was months
ago it's not like it's you know may 1st
you're like okay well where's the
position which you would have had a
right to but you're not doing that
you've given it plenty of time and i
think it's very reasonable for you to go
to whoever your leader is whoever the
decision maker is that that made this
promise and so on and put it back on
them say hey here's what we said here's
what we agreed to and then here's the
timeline that that hasn't happened and i
and be very complimentary not as a
source of manipulation you mean it you
love this company you love the work you
love the culture you just don't want the
tax burden you want them to do what they
said they would do and i think you can
say that in a very
kind way yeah but very direct that puts
puts a little bit of fire under them to
do something about it yes because i mean
in a way too don't lock yourself into
this one thing right i mean there are
other great companies that have work to
work from home i mean like what you need
and what you want
is out there so don't pigeonhole
yourself into this one thing even though
you you love it and you want it
when you at least know in the back of
your mind i have a plan b and a plan c
it's going to help you because it's
going to give you the freedom to be able
to let go if you need to if they don't
follow through because the deal is too
you get stuck in this
cycle of frustration
when a conversation like chrissy just
laid out doesn't happen so lay it out
clear terms a time frame to know what's
going on but then in the back your mind
hunter i would have plan b and c just to
say okay i have something else to fall
back on this is not the end-all be-all
of my career yeah that's good and good
luck good luck i think if you stick with
it you'll end up right where you're
supposed to be yeah all right we're
gonna go to bethesda maryland with yakov
hi how are you
hi i'm doing great what about you great
how can rachel i help
hi i
started uh watching the show about a
week ago and uh today i started
reading or listening to
total money makeover yeah awesome
just a newbie
the question i have is
i'm going back to school in january
and now that i'm reading the book i want
to
be debt-free as much as i can and
i would
i'm working online but going to school i
would need to have a car
so
it will be a second car for us and
if i use the bus
then it will be
hour and a half each direction but if i
buy a car that gives me some extra time
to
work extra hours so i was thinking
it would be a
good compromise buying a car and then
use the money from the work to pay for
the car
but
it's still half a year uh ahead so i was
thinking maybe i could save some so it's
not uh 100 dead
so what's your recommendation yeah well
it's a it's a great question um
i'll say this we are about 100 no debt
at all so my goal for you
um would be to pay for a car in cash and
i'll be honest it may not be the
prettiest car it may not be the best car
it may not be your dream car uh but to
do what you need it to do to get you to
and from work versus avoiding the bus
and an hour and a half commute both ways
with that
this is a great investment so how much
um
are you and are you married did you say
yes okay how much do you guys make a
year
uh we make
right now about 60 to 80. okay
yep um and
what kind of debt do you guys have
we have 5 000 credit card and 75 on
student loan 75 000 okay
so
what this would be uh we talk about our
four walls a lot more budgeting taking a
budget and saying okay here here's the
priority of things that we need to take
care of
and that would be food
shelter
transportation and utilities so
transportation's in there which is a car
and so in order for you to go to work go
to school do these things you're going
to need a car so
do you guys i don't have to have a car
but i will be saving on time that i can
use towards like
extra hours on work yeah absolutely do
you guys have any savings at all
no we just started yes oh it's great
sorry one quick question did you say
your student loan was 75 000 or seventy
five hundred
uh seventy five four thousand okay i
just wanna clear for that yeah so
if you were to choose to say yes and a
car would be an investment for us to
make this process easier i can work
overtime i can do x y and z
i would not take out a car payment for
it again this is going to be a very
cheap
cheap reliable car
an old honda an old accord i love hondas
hondas are my favorites you're on a
honda i am
but the goal here is to completely avoid
debt 100
and if this is something that you guys
say yeah we need to invest in this
before we start paying off the debts i
would do that and then i'd get gazelle
intense and you guys are on it i mean
you're in it for the first week and i'm
so excited so excited about your money
journey
awesome this is the ramsay show
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
if you've been paying attention to the
real estate market you've noticed that
competition between buyers out there is
intense in part because the inventory of
available housing has been hitting
all-time lows
now when inventory is low it simply
means there are more buyers buying than
sellers selling and that turns the
pressure up on everyone if you've been
looking you've been feeling that
buyers want to snag the right house
sellers want to accept the right offer
this isn't amateur hour y'all low
inventory is here to stay
to win in this market you need a pro by
your side
that's why we find vet and endorse top
real estate agents across the country
called endorsed local providers to help
you
buy or sell our agents have years of
industry success and refuse to
compromise your financial goals no
matter how tough the competition is
good news is that you can instantly
connect with an endorsed local provider
in your area today just go to
ramseysolutions.com
agent to find a ramsey trusted agent
near you that's ramseysolutions.com
agent
and blinds.com 100 satisfaction
guarantee means that even if you
mismeasure or pick the wrong color
they'll remake your blinds for free you
get free samples free shipping and with
the new promo codes they run every month
you'll save even more use promo code
ramsay to get the best deal
and today's question comes from kcn
missouri
my husband and i have been battling
infertility for three years we have no
debt and our income is 40 thousand
dollars and we have 10 000 in savings we
have tried less aggressive fertility
treatments and they have failed
it looks like we will have to move on to
ivf which can be ten to fifteen thousand
dollars
taking out a loan in order to do i ivf
doesn't feel right but neither does
spending all of our life savings on
something that isn't guaranteed
what advice do you have for families who
long for a baby and can't afford the
cost of ivf
i've thought about selling baked goods
or craft projects to raise funds is fund
raising a good option
okay see this is this is a hard one i
think that this is um
something in life that
i think everyone has had someone in
their life where this
this has been the case the struggle of
of starting a family and i think it's
one of the most heart-wrenching ones
um issues so i don't um
you know
i don't belittle that at all because
that it is um it's it's heartbreaking
it's absolutely heartbreaking um
so when you i would say
it doesn't feel right to spend all of
our life savings on something that isn't
guaranteed
i think trying for a baby
is worth it
i think for you guys um you're right
it's not guaranteed and so taking out
loans for this is difficult because i've
talked to people that have done this and
and if it didn't work you know you're
paying back some memory that it did
and it causes a lot it does cause a lot
of stress and so
uh my encouragement to you would be um
yes this fundraising option absolutely i
think people uh are extremely generous
in life i think people
start you know whether it's gofundme
start places and people love on them and
and help give and support to their
causes whether it's adoption or ivf or
whatever you choose um it's it's a
beautiful thing so yes is that an option
absolutely it's an option it's on the
table i would say uh but i'd also say
that you guys can um
i think you can i think you can cash
flow
at least one of these treatments because
i know on the front end end of this it's
usually more expensive through the
process
but i would say to still keep that
emergency fund i would still have money
to make i wouldn't i wouldn't cash out
everything and go to zero by any means
um that doesn't feel wise either i
understand that so i would have some
buffer maybe you bring your emergency
fund down to three months versus six
months and and you guys have that and
then be aggressively saving for this
goal because this is a goal of something
you guys are longing for as a family and
and using that motivation to say you
know what
we're gonna cut things out of our
lifestyle we are we're gonna i'm gonna
sell baked goods i'm gonna sell crafts
i'm gonna fundraise we're gonna do what
we can
to get this money and let that longing
for a family be part of that motivation
to save for it i really would and um but
this is hard it's hard this is a hard
question yeah and the the other thing
casey that i would say is this feels
super emotional for you
because it is super emotional for you
but if you were to just for a minute
suspend the emotion of it and look at it
differently and say this is something
very important to us
and we're gonna find a way to pay for it
just like you would if it was anything
else that was super important to you it
feels different because it's a baby
obviously that is different but don't
feel weird about saving up to pay cash
or using cash from your from your
savings account that you already have or
adding to it or fundraising to fund this
thing that's very important to you it
just so happens that this thing that you
want to spend money on is a baby and
thank god for modern medicine that there
are options like this for you to um
pursue that path and so i i just want to
encourage you that um while it is
extremely emotional and personal you
have every right
and opportunity that within your means
to um to find a way to pay for it if
that's what's right for you and that's
what you want to do so we just want to
encourage you in that
all right let's go to beaumont texas
with daniel hey daniel how are you
good how are y'all good what's going on
uh so i'm thinking about
taking another job
um the job that i'm i'm at and pays
really really good but it's shift work
and um we have a new baby and everything
and i'm just i'm only home half the time
and when i am home i'm sleeping you know
and um
i'm just trying to get some guidance on
it because i'm going to take about a
2 000 a month cut
to move jobs
um so what's your income right now
right now uh monthly
or annual either one
uh monthly is 7 400 and i'd be
going down to about 5 400.
don't have any debt
yeah
yeah i have a mortgage and then
i have 20 thousand dollars on my truck
and thirty five thousand on my wife's
suv
yeah so is it span twenty thousand in
student loans
so when you say the better hours is it
because you're exhausted at your job or
because you're missing the baby or both
uh both you know i work nights
um
nights and days it alternates
so
half the time i'm not home
and then half the time when i'm home you
know i'm sleeping or whatever because my
schedule is all crazy
and
i just and then of course once
she gets older and everything
you know like all the guys i work with
they don't
they miss their kids you know recital
dance recitals football games basketball
games all that they just
everybody's making good money but
they're kind of miserable because they
don't they're not really free you know
and daniel holds the baby
she's 10 months old 10 months old okay
well daniel you just made i'm gonna let
rachel answer this but i just want to
point out you just made the perfect case
for why you guys need to get out of debt
because you get out of debt and you get
serious and you get on a budget and if
you stay on the line we'll have kelly
give you guys a membership to ramsey
plus so you can take the classes learn
the steps get the every dollar budget if
you do that now
when she's a baby and will have zero
memories of what's going on right now of
you working these nights then when she's
older in a couple years you guys get
this debt knocked out you can take that
pay cut you can be at her recitals and
you can do all of that but that will not
happen if you're always in chains to
this debt i'll let rachel take it but
you just made a perfect case for why we
need to get out of here yes absolutely i
was gonna say this is your why i mean
daniel let this to say i don't want to
be those guys you know my baby's 10
months you know she's not doing recitals
right now she's not doing he's not doing
basketball games right now but that's
coming like that day is coming it's
coming fast in the next couple of years
and you guys kind of got a mess on your
hands financially lots of debt stuff
kind of swirling around so i would say
let this be your motivator
yes would you have a better quality of
life right now in the present if you
took those hours down yes you would
absolutely and is that the right
decision maybe it is maybe you guys
decide you know what we're still going
to cut the hours and we're going to
attack this debt it's going to take us
longer to pay it off but the more you
buckle down right now like christy's
saying and the more you say i'm going to
sacrifice my time with my family
to still make this extra because i mean
you're you're talking about you know 25
grand
pay cut um over a year
that could be thrown at this debts
so
do the math and say how fast can we get
out of debt if i stayed in this job how
long would it be this is not forever
but 18 24 months what does it look like
in two years if i don't take the pay
cuts and we grind it out even though
it's going to be hard it might be worth
it in the end
so good this is the ramsay show
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
scripture of the day is luke 11 9 and
10. so i say to you ask and it will be
given to you
seek and you will find knock and the
door will be open to you for everyone
who asks receives the one who seeks
finds
and to the one who knocks the door will
be opened
maya angelou said ask for what you want
and be prepared to get it such a theme
today ask so often we miss the simple
things just ask for what you want and
ask for what you need i love that all
right we're going to go to alexa in
colorado hey alexa how are you
hi guys thank you for taking my call sir
what's going on
um so
my husband and i started the baby steps
back in july
finally got on the same page and
you know did our first budget and
everything um awesome so we're just a
little worried because of a car
situation
um both cars are actually paid for and
it has always been that way and even
before i started listening to you guys
it was my pride and joy you know i we
never owed anything on a car
but but my my husband's a little worried
because you know they're both i think
one of them for 2004 and the others in
2006.
they're both pretty heavy especially
mine is pretty heavy on the miles with
cooking up the kids and drop-offs and
just everything um so i wanted to know
what the best way to plan for that is or
you know i mean we just started on the
baby steps and we've kind of struggled a
little bit to
really get some friction going here you
know let's get some
i don't know some
um
yeah and so i'm just a little
bummed out you know that we would i mean
i don't know i guess i didn't know the
the best way to
to cancel this track into that we don't
end up having to take a car loan out or
whatever you know sure alexa is there
problems with the car currently or
you're just worried because they're an
0-4 and 0-6 and you just you just know
eventually cars give out is there any
reason
besides just
my husband's car which is mainly just
for him to go to work and back you know
it's actually turned out to be pretty
reliable
so is there anything wrong with the cars
though are you
is there anything wrong currently with
the cars that you're like okay we have
to replace the transmission all that or
you just
are fearful in the future not right now
because
the main one is like over 200 000 miles
already okay yeah yeah for sure
um which cars still run then i
understand they're more likely to break
the older they are but we're doing good
we're doing good uh where are you guys
in the baby steps are you on baby step
one are you on baby step two
yeah just number one okay i was actually
dropped so
we had to readjust our budget just this
month okay amazing and what's the debt
situation
uh i think we're at about ten thousand
okay
ten thousand total is that credit cards
student loans
um mainly credit cards actually okay
yeah that's great
but a little bit of student loans and
how much do you guys make a year
uh we're at about
80 000 um before texas
amazing okay well alexa
i mean i'm i'm gonna be
shooter straight she needs it shoot her
straight i can feel it and you you're
holding back she makes 80 000. she has
ten thousand dollars
you can get out i'm about to give you
good news alexa like you can do this
like this is easy we got this you make
eighty thousand dollars
you guys need to do a written budget you
need to cut out everything alexa
everything you guys have been enjoying
life you've been racking up some credit
card debt here and there
you gotta stop that you gotta look at
your budget you gotta cut everything out
of it and you guys can get this thousand
dollars quickly you can do this
sell stuff work extra
you go that's the interesting thing that
i i guess i am like i felt the same way
which is why i was so eager to
have my husband jump on board with me
yeah then we sat down and did the budget
and and i mean literally we haven't gone
out since july what um we have really
money going where's it all going do you
have too much mortgage um i i think it's
my mortgage yeah i think we just got the
house back in december
um so the mortgage and the bills is what
percent of your income is your mortgage
oh goodness
at um point again because my hours just
dropped so they got cut back
um at this point we're probably like
closer to that half
50 yep and we also have yeah and we also
have three young kids so there's daycare
involved
yep
yeah alex i think your house is a big
problem it's eating a lot of that money
um
and you guys just gotta tighten stuff up
i mean like yes even if half your money
goes
to a mortgage payment which again you
got too much house you guys may really
really really want to look down run the
numbers and consider hey what if what if
we sold what if we did something
different in this situation
um but you guys make 80 grand so it's
there
it's there
uh it's just a matter of you guys
sitting down and saying no to everything
everything for a season for a season and
it's going to be hard it's not going to
be comfortable but listen alexa
the deeper you sacrifice that lifestyle
the deeper you say i'm gonna my hours
were cut but i'm gonna find extra
somewhere else like we are going
to to work hard again for a season and
sacrifice time sacrifice lifestyle
to get this to get this all moving
it's gonna be worth it because if you
guys really do buckle down you're gonna
you're gonna be able people the average
income is what 56 thousand dollars in
america
so within
within six months you guys should be
able to clean all this up and i really
really believe you guys can you're
working as a team but you're new to this
okay so give yourself some grace you're
new to this it's gonna feel
uncomfortable yeah and alexa i want you
to stay on the line because you have the
income you there's no reason you can't
get yourself out of this mess it's going
to take some adjustment like rachel said
but stay on the line i want kelly to
give you
a year to ramsay plus you're going to
get the class financial peace university
i want you and your spouse to take this
class together this class is not only
going to show you how to get out of debt
in a tactical way it's going to fire you
up to care enough to want to because
most of us know what we need to do
to to
you know
get out of debt live on less than we
make we know this we know how to lose
weight eat less calories we get it we
just don't
have the motivation a lot of times and
what's so fantastic about financial
peace university is it gives you the
information and the motivation it's
going to fire you up to want to do
something about this situation which is
exactly what you need right now and
what's great is you already have the
income to work with now here's the other
thing that i think is important for you
to know alexa but also any of you out
there
if you are in a situation
where you are living paycheck to
paycheck
and you're just getting by and you're
just keeping your head above water
you have to make adjustments to make
progress
you will never make progress on your
debt or your financial goals
by keeping the situation how it is where
you're just keeping your head above
water which means here let's talk about
that what that means literally
it means you have to get your income up
and you have to get your expenses down
so there is a larger margin between your
income and your expenses all that extra
is what you've got to work with right
like that's what goes towards your debt
or towards your goals or whatever so
alexa even if you make 80 000 a year if
half of it's gone to the mortgage and a
whole larger chunk is going to child
care you may need to take a second job
or your spouse takes the second job or
you sell the house something has to
change
to decrease the expenses to increase the
income or maybe both in order to have
margin to make progress guys if you're
okay
with barely just getting by
you're never gonna get out of debt
you're never going to make progress
you have to get fired up i love how dave
says you can wander into debt you cannot
wander out what got you in this mess by
degrees a little here a little there is
not what's going to get you out a little
here little there never got anyone out
of debt ever you've got to get gazelle
intense you've got to get your income up
your expenses down in whatever way
is possible for you
and that's what's going to make the
difference
not i'm going to save two dollars on a
coffee
two dollars on a coffee is fine but i
need you to make major changes
to increase your income and decrease
your expenses to get there and it's
gonna feel uncomfortable alexa it's not
gonna be fun change is uncomfortable it
is and this is gonna say it causes
friction and it's hard like it it is
it makes you step out of your comfort
zone to say this is not normal what i
knew was normal is not getting me what i
want
so the results that i want
in the future
in order to get this i have to change my
present i have to change what i've been
doing just like what christie's saying
and so prepare for that friction prepare
to be uncomfortable and there's a level
of this it's not easy if it was easy
everyone would be doing it right so so
it's gonna take a level of discipline
for you guys but alexa you can do this
and you guys are so early on in the
process okay you got to just fine tune
some stuff get that fire lit in you and
ramsay plus is going to help you do that
and you can change the game it is hard
but it is worth it no one has called us
and said oh man i miss my debt no one
ever by the way it's worth it
all right i want to thank producer james
childs and associate producer kelly
daniel my co-host rachel cruz christmas
is fun and you
america for listening in this is the
ramsey show
[Music]
have a friend or family member that
needs a daily dose of ramsay advice in
their life let them know about the
ramsey call of the day podcast it's a
quick hit of advice about life and money
in under 10 minutes check out the ramsey
call of the day podcast wherever you
listen to podcasts
[Music]
you